you remember what annuities are what's
different between an annuity and like
just a regular bank account which you've
got already and it's going what's the
difference
okay very good as the name suggests on
an annual basis pretty much you're
continually putting more money into
there and that's why it grows so
superannuation is the biggest example
with the most common example of an
annuity this is the kind of our final
field sort of mathematics that we end up
having to deal with because if it
changes every year you've got to keep on
recalculating every year the compound
interest formula doesn't do it for you
because what does the compound interest
formula deal with you put money in and
then what happens
yeah just occurred interested just tired
Parsons right but this is different
each subsequent year you start to
reinsert more money and that additional
money gets waitress then we noticed
pretty quickly this is a very laborious
way to go about it
it wasn't the only way I showed you you
can also you can also use a table and
you can say alright I've been there for
five years on five different occasions
at the beginning of U&D of whatever you
would put in your sum of money right and
so that first sum of money that you put
in it's going to be in there for a grand
total of how to make use and you could
work out interest and the same thing for
the next group ammonia and the next
group and the last room money you can
add little more bizarre but this is
still kind of a pain okay so what we're
going to have a look at today is what
happens when we try and automate that
process for you and say alright we know
what you have to watch it through all of
the calculations what if we provide you
with some information to help to do this
okay so if you've got that there turn
over to the next page and you'll see
this monstrosity now it looks awful but
it's trying to save you some work and it
really does save you so much if you know
how to read it
okay you've seen something like this
before but it's been a while I want you
to look right at the top of the right at
the top and in fact this is so important
it's worth writing down so intersecting
earlier write down after I tell to you
this table is all about this and if you
understand this is one two three four
five
as the numbers if you understand that
you understand the whole table okay what
this table tells you each of these
numbers here it's what happens to an
individual dollar if it gets invested to
sundown time and you want to figure out
well in the future how much will that
dollar end up being equivalent to okay
so just before we move up for example
Hubbell details you notice you can see
the blur again have a look at this one
here okay have a look at the column have
a look at the row what does it mean to
be in this column has that refer to here
okay so this is the interest rate that
I've got on my own Uwe T investment
whatever it's okay if I'm in this row
what does this mean over here
okay so this is the second year right so
you can see what's happened is what's
happened to this right you've had the 3%
interest that's been pretty right why is
there two there you put in you put in
another dollar
do you remember this the whole idea of
annuities is you keep on putting you
right so this is like a dollar and then
there's a dollar with the three percent
interest and that's where the 2.03 comes
from does that make sense now what just
happened what I just said in last 10
seconds that took you like five lines to
write and so that just says look just go
straight there go straight there if
you're putting in a dollar every time
then in the second year for that
interest rate this is what we'll end up
with if you want to go further down in
time you can see it grow how that works
say for example here ten periods right
and you can see how big disadvantage
okay now give you your calculator just
go
again I want to make this contrast
between an annuity and if you're doing
just compound interest okay now to
Kolkata just what we are in easy and not
for opportunities remember it starts as
an egg what about that comparison
correct it one oh wait I have brackets
know something before about the
principal and then inside the bracket
and then I'm sorry
good so what this tells you is if you've
got a principal view method for an
amount of time at a certain rate this is
what you get out now have a look I've my
pockets have a good flat area so that
period ten
what is it belong this one then it's the
amount of time the number of time
element attempt up there what goes
inside the bracket into 1 plus or you
give a wheel particularly a very fancy
right yep so three percent that was
would be the way I write it in decimal
and have a look again at the title how
many dollars are my investing 1 okay now
go ahead crunch that true what do you go
yes one point one three point three nine
one point three four yeah okay so this
is what happens if you put the dollar in
and then you just let it sit there for
10 years but look at this what's going
on why does number so enormous you know
because you can't come putting dollars
in right so this the lion's share of
this is the $1 that you kept on
inserting and then the one point four
six three nine that's the extra interest
that you've accrued just does that make
sense that's why these numbers that take
off so quickly because you keep
reinvesting okay so how would we
summarize this are underneath the
heading of I suppose you'd call this
future values from tables as a lot
important future values for our tables
[Applause]
this setting is so important because
people look at the table and they don't
know how to interpret they didn't how to
use it they don't understand it's trying
to save you time and effort and
calculate a button battery I think
future values containers the selves each
describe the value of the annuity after
any number of periods and any interest
rate when you continually reinvest and
nearly after n time periods and after
sense of interest and this is important
if you've got enough time like I
probably write in the car and you
continually reinvest this is kind of the
thing that makes annuities annuities
it's why it's got its own ethnic bias
thing this is the big idea that's why
this table is necessary because if we
didn't continually reinvest just get
your calculator out just put in to
compound interest or no that's all you
need to do okay yeah let's have a look
at a question to see how to answer
business oh by the way you can see down
the bottom here just have a look at it
and tell me how it's different to the
previous one look if there's two big
differences okay number one yeah when
you have a look at these time periods
over here are they're growing in much
larger numbers why do you think they're
growing so quickly 12 24 36 they're in
multiples of 12 your lines dimension is
right so they carefully say period up
here rather than say here because it
might be calculated on a different basis
like monthly a monthly is what I would
guess based on the back of their twelves
360 is not what is 300
común last probably isn't that 30 years
why do you think this ends at 30 years
why do you get a good place to end
that's how long it takes to repay like
oh now be careful yeah this isn't this
is not a repayment it's not irritated
this is us excuse me put any money in
that's kind of a clue over what time
period are you putting money here
how are you while you're watching right
you start working and then hopefully at
some point in their not-too-distant
future
you get to retiring say all right over
my lifetime this is how much I've
invested from here to here yeah okay so
let's have a look at this that's a good
question and by the way the first table
also does it by the way if I yeah 48 54
60 100 this reminds you when I was
accounting for like you know playing
hide-and-seek one two three hundred
Beckerman um why does it suddenly go
from 12 which is 12 and then it just
suddenly said to forget 12 why does it
do that w 120 in months 120 months in
Sony is 10 years which makes this look
10 years another 60 months that's 10 and
then 15 years and then 20 25 30 I think
the assumption is that as you think
about larger time scale you don't really
care I can't either play or what will I
have in 23 years when we're thinking
that finally just kind of round another
25 years 30 years in the future
that's enough level of detail for me now
by the way can I just perform you're off
distant how look at some question
connection to point out I'll probably
get big numbers down yeah they're really
big what what was the quantity we
started talking about when we looked at
the very top and we're down this
description what quantity are we talking
about that turned into this if there is
one thing you get out of study F Empire
is that if you invest a dollar early on
if it can
and there for a long time then that one
dollar admittedly reinvested it for a
period of time but a dollar it turns
really big right this is a really big
deal a dollar over 30 years that's um
that's $30 $30 actually physically put
in there and look into what that became
and this is at the lowest interest rate
by the way there was another difference
than maybe didn't wander have a look at
the interest rates and look at these and
then put them back up to the top why the
interest rate is different compared to
different remember this is we were
probably thinking easier right so when
you have a look down here and you
suggested to me this is probably in
months so 0.2 percent per month if you
do that by 12 what's that me you 0.2
times 2 well it's too early in the
morning for my friends I kind of
arithmetic that's 2.4 percent okay so
2.4 percent per annum
because this per month does that make
sense so let me just recap each of these
cells is a dollar that's reinvested
every year look carefully at your time
periods and carefully at the interest
rate okay the types of some questions
turnover if there's two of you either
desk you've got a computer he conceded
maybe one of you wants to be on this
page and then another wants to be